why did Tom Cruise become an actor I
just love movies and I wanted to make
movies and I remember as a kid I used to
create characters and write skits and I
always kind of did outrageous physical
stunts also can only imagine what it
might have been your mother I feel I
mean just look out the window while
you're doing the dishes and there's your
seven-year-old son like trying a stunt
and breaking an arm or a leg because yes
you were injuring yourself all the time
my mother uh most definitely had
incredible patience did Tom Cruise
really hang off the plane yes I did hang
off the a400 I remember the second take
actually when we went through it I got
hit with just a little a little rock I
mean it must have been about that big
and I honestly was like getting hit by a
bullet but the thing I was most
concerned about was a fuel you know the
fumes from that in the air uh that was
hitting me particularly on the when we
were taxing on the runway because it had
nowhere else to go it's quite an
adventure don't necessarily recommend it
for everyone but you know it was
interesting